[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend von den bränden in
griechenland und der türkei gibt es
eindrückliche berichte und bilder von
einer der griechischen inseln konnten
sich die menschen letzte nacht nur noch
durch die flucht aufs meer retten
um eine vorstellung von der
größenordnung zu geben um die es hier
geht im schlimmen dürre jahr 2018 als es
in deutschland besonders viele und
schwere waldbrände gab verbrannte
insgesamt eine fläche von rund 2300
hektar in griechenland sollen allein
durch die aktuellen brände von 60.000
hektar vernichtet sein der türkei nach
ersten schätzungen mehr als 100000 das
sind ganze landschaften die danach kaum
wiederzuerkennen sind wie in den beiden
ländern gegen die katastrophe an
gekämpft wird berichtet kamen safia
sie muss aus ihrem haus geholt werden
eine einwohnerin eines vororts von athen
die polizei bittet hier viele gegen
ihren willen
die flammen sind bedrohlich nahe es ist
wirklich schlimm ganz griechenland rennt
gerade ab noch in der nacht hatten hier
viele freiwillige helfer versucht die
feuerwalze aufzuhalten mit einfachsten
mitteln unter lebensgefahr
bei kaum auszuhalten temperaturen
irgendwo im rauch hilfeschreie die
häuser brennen schnell holt hilfe wasser
alle versuchen sich in sicherheit zu
bringen
unterdessen wird die kritik an den
behörden immer lauter waren die feuer
auf den berg aber da war keine
löschtrupp dann sind die flammen zu uns
hier runter bekommen
neben dem großraum athen brennt es vor
allem auf der halbinsel peloponnes und
der insel euböa insgesamt über 60
brandherde auf föhr ist die lage
kritisch das feuer frisst sich meter für
meter weiter mehr als 1300 menschen
mussten hier in der nacht per fähre
gerettet werden
die flammen hatten den landweg
abgestanden gesichtern der google nur
der region forderten der feuerwehrleute
und löschflugzeuge
deutschland hat inzwischen hilfe
zugesagt auch griechenlands
regierungschef verspricht schnelle hilfe
ich möchte all denen die von den feuern
betroffen sind versichern sie sind meine
oberste priorität
wenn dieser albtraumhafte sommer zu ende
ist werden wir alle schäden so schnell
wie möglich beheben
auch in der türkei brennt es in der
region antalya sind nach regenfällen
viele feuer unter kontrolle
doch in der region marmaris bieten sie
weiter wie hier in köln kies kämpfen die
einsatzkräfte verzweifelt gegen die
flammen vom boden und aus der luft
es sind die schlimmsten waldbrände in
der türkei seit 13 jahren bilanz bisher
acht tote dort steht unser türkei
korrespondent luk von der christen union
wurde ja tagelang immer wieder haben wir
darüber berichtet vergeblich auf die
löschflugzeuge gewartet wie steht es
denn inzwischen um die brandbekämpfung
besser wesentlich besser muss man sagen
was wir hier am boden mitbekommen das
ist besser koordiniert das ist auch viel
effizienter das hat zum teil damit zu
tun dass löschflugzeuge und ganz viele
helikopter da sind aus dem ausland die
flugzeuge helikopter aber auch teilweise
jetzt von der türkischen gendarmerie und
von den forstbehörden aber die arbeit am
boden ist viel effizienter
das hat damit zu tun dass die städte
sich organisiert haben
es trifft hilfe wir waren heute mit dem
einsatzleiter hier vor ort unterwegs ist
trifft hilfe ein anrufer aus allen
städten aus größeren städten der türkei
man bietet an löschfahrzeuge
unterstützung logistik material auf
mannschaften
das ist sehr gut organisiert aber zur
wahrheit gehört die behörden haben lange
lange lange gebraucht bis sie reagiert
haben insbesondere die staatlichen
zentralen behörden aus ankara und sagte
heute ein einsatzleiter hier wenn die
das heer der hunderten ja tausenden
freiwilligen helfer nicht gewesen wäre
die sofort zupackend hilfe angeboten
haben auch hier hinter uns sind heute
abend wieder dutzende unterwegs dann
werden die auswirkungen dieser
katastrophalen feuer noch viel größer
gewesen
ein glück für diese beschreibung und
eindrücke aus der türkei und dann
schalten wir nach griechenland auch noch
zu dominik löschmeistern athen nimmt die
feuerwehr hatte angekündigt sie will
zumindestens die brände im norden athens
irgendwie bis heute abend unter
kontrolle bringen ist das sehr gelungen
nach seiner beobachtung
ja die situation im norden von athen ist
jetzt besser
die feuerwehr und fahnen der
katastrophenschutz hat heute abend noch
einmal gesagt dass man jetzt ein
großteil der brände dort unter kontrolle
hat und jetzt das militär eingesetzt hat
als brandwachen weil man muss auch
wissen das natürlich in der nacht mit
winden
diese glutnester auch wieder anfangen
können zu brennen und da besteht
natürlich auch eine gefahr für die nacht
aber es ist in griechenland moment sind
eigentlich zwei andere bereiche viel
kritischer dass es zum einen die
halbinsel peloponnes und dann die insel
euböa und auf dieser insel
da bereitet man sich moment vor weitere
menschen in sicherheit zu bringen zwölf
orte sind aktuell von den bränden
bedroht und die marine die griechische
marine hat schiffe militärschiffe in
bereitstellung und bereit gehalten um
diese menschen in sicherheit zu bringen
und das konnte heute nacht und ja das
könnte es noch bange stunden werden
dankeschön nach athen dominik
löschmeistern kommen wir zu einer
anderen heimsuchen unserer zeit der
pandemie und blicken nach frankreich
dort sind die korona zahlen zuletzt
wieder kräftig gestiegen besonders in
den urlaubsregionen an der
mittelmeerküste
das rki hat deshalb ja auch unter
anderem die côte d'azur und korsika zu
hoch risikogebieten erklärt die
französische regierung hat weitere
beschränkungen verhängt die ab montag
gelten dann gilt in cafés restaurants
und an diversen weiteren orten reinkommt
nur noch wer geimpft genesen oder
getestet ist die mehrheit der
französischen bevölkerung ist damit zwar
einverstanden und auch die französischen
verfassungshüter haben das abgesegnet
doch es gibt auch wütende proteste eine
art berichtet aus paris im kapelle aus
dem sommerurlaub frankreichs präsident
setzt auf tägliche kurzvideos um seine
landsleute an ihre verantwortung in der
korona krise zu erinnerung
lassen sie sich impfen das ist eine
bürgerpflicht freiheit ist nur etwas
wert wenn man die freiheit der anderen
schützt damit richtet er sich auch an
all jene die nun schon das vierte
wochenende in folge demonstrieren gegen
gesundheitspass und impfpflicht für
krankenhaus und pflegepersonal
nachdem es in frankreich lange so gut
wie keine massenproteste gegen die
pandemie politik gab
scheint sich nun eine angestaute wut zu
entladen
seit eineinhalb jahren seit beginn der
pandemie haben wir immer weniger
freiheiten
sie haben uns eingesperrt wir dürfen
nirgendwo mehr gesundheitspass ist nur
dafür da uns zu gängeln uns
vorzuschreiben was wir dürfen und was
nicht
so zumindest interpretieren die
rechtsextremen die deutliche
verschärfung der regeln
dabei soll das gesetz eigentlich die
vierte corona welle brechen vorbeugen
dass maßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen
die erneut alle einschränken einige
regionen in südfrankreich hat
deutschland bereits zum hochrisiko
gebiet erklärt betont oder virgin
wir bekommen das jetzt in den
krankenhäusern zu spüren eine zahl die
das deutlich macht in diesem krankenhaus
etwa hat sich die zahl der kurve
patienten innerhalb einer woche
vervierfachte bierbach kath auffällig
ist dass in jenen regionen besonders
heftig protestiert wird wo die impfquote
niedrig ist wie hier in lyon makros
politik empfinden viele als bevormundung
merkur der präsident spaltet das land
und er provoziert anfeindungen
er hat als person mit einem enormen
vertrauensverlust zu kämpfen das stellen
wir leider so fest und zu offenbaren die
proteste auch wie zerrissen frankreichs
gesellschaft ist sie könnten den
wahlkampf für die präsidentschaftswahl
in neun monaten ein wollten
und mit den aktuellen kroner zahlen in
deutschland macht jetzt heinz weiter bei
der sieben tage incidents hat sich die
steigende tendenz fortgesetzt
die zahlen im einzelnen das robert koch
institut registrierte 3206
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden 806
mehr als vor einer woche
24 weitere todesfälle im zusammenhang
mit kuwait 19 wurden gemeldet die sieben
tage incidents liegt jetzt bei 21,2 im
streit zwischen der eu und polen über
justizreformen hat warschau in einem
wichtigen punkt eine änderung
angekündigt die umstrittene
disziplinarkammer für richter werde in
ihrer jetzigen form aufgelöst erklärte
der chef der regierungspartei pis
jaroslaw kaczynski der
nachrichtenagentur ap der europäische
gerichtshof hatte mitte juli geurteilt
die disziplinarkammer verstoße gegen eu
recht weil sie nicht alle garantien für
unparteilichkeit und unabhängigkeit
biete in mehreren deutschen städten gab
es heute demonstrationen für eine
unterstützung der zivilen seenotrettung
im mittelmeer aufgerufen hatten
verschiedene hilfs organisationen wie
amnesty international oder ärzte ohne
grenzen die schiffe cbot 3 und außen
weidling bekamen heute die erlaubnis mit
mehr als 800 geflüchteten in sizilien
anzulegen nach angaben der vereinten
nationen ertranken dieses jahr bei der
flucht über das mittelmeer schon mehr
als 1000 menschen am tagebau garzweiler
in nordrhein westfalen haben rund 2500
menschen für einen schnelleren ausstieg
aus der braunkohleförderung demonstriert
sie bildeten eine vier kilometer lange
menschenkette und forderten den
kohleausstieg bis spätestens 2030 die
bundesregierung will auf 2038 auf den
abbau von braunkohle verzichten
eine meldung vom dfb pokal da gab es
heute in runde eins das erste aus für
einen bundesligisten aufsteiger greuther
fürth hat beim regionalligisten sv
babelsberg verloren mit 5 4 im
elfmeterschießen
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
9 14 18 19 30 40 superzahl 3 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
die wetteraussichten für morgen im
südwesten und osten größere sonnige
abschnitte sonst wechselnd oder stark
bewölkt mit schauern und gewittern
höchstwerte 17 bis 25 grad in der neuen
woche im norden und nordwesten weiterhin
wechselhaft im süden viel sonne und
trocken temperaturen ist 27 grad
die deutsche wetterlage bewegt natürlich
vor allem jenen die gerade urlaub daheim
in deutschland machen und das sind in
diesem sommer sehr viele ostseestadt
côte d'azur weniger wetterbeständig aber
dafür sind die strände länger und
breiter
uwe dom ist da eines der top ziele und
neben strandkörben und butterfahrten
gibt es noch einen besonderen
urlaubsservice den sich der landkreis
für die besucher seiner ferienregion
ausgedacht hat im kaller cup mosebach
über deutschen urlaub in kroner zeiten
der parkplatz direkt vor einem
freizeitpark auf usedom sondern fraktion
des landkreises für einheimische und
urlauber ohne termin zwei impfstoffe
stehen zur auswahl
die verantwortlichen wissen die vierte
welle droht kreativität ist gefragt bei
der steigerung der impfquote auch jetzt
in der urlaubszeit
und bin nie zu hause nie 14 tage weg
sondern in sondershausen zum irgendwann
komme ich nicht und etwa die chance die
jetzt zu nutzen
wir wollten sowieso wir hätten es jetzt
irgendwann wahrscheinlich innerhalb der
ferien sowieso auch in guter unserer
heimatstadt versucht dadurch dass es
hier jetzt ohne termin möglich war war
das sehr angenehm für uns sie für uns
als landkreis in der gegenwärtigen phase
der pandemie ist es den impfstoff in die
fläche zu bringen zum bürger zu bringen
möglichst das impfangebot dazu
unterbreiten wo die bürger sind und hier
sind sie die bürger viele zumindest im
urlaub auf usedom
die insel ist so gut wie ausgebucht
200.000 urlaubsgäste füllen die strände
pandemie rituale am frühstücksbuffet
mittlerweile routine für hotelier
christa wenige und seine gäste sieben
monate zwangsschließung umsatzeinbußen
um 30 prozent im letzten und wohl auch
in diesem jahr zehn prozent des
personals sind abgewandert so die bilanz
des hoteliers der auch chef des
branchenverbandes ist also die preise
haben sich entwickelt im letzten und in
diesem jahr zusammen um circa 15 prozent
nach oben
wegen corona wegen corona letzten endes
ja auch die campingplätze der insel sind
rappelvoll nur mit viel glück findet
sich noch eine lücke openair urlaub
liegt im trend in dieser saison
erfolgreich negativ getestet es darf
bleiben und gern auch wieder kommen
der zweite urlaub sommer unter pandemie
bedingungen auf usedom läuft bisher wie
der erste der start in die saison
verspätet die preise angezogen und die
stimmung bestens
trotz allem damit verschenken sie doch
auch gerne von heute journal und um 0.55
gibt es dann die nächste heute express
[Musik]